this is a seed it doesn't look like much
right now but if you put it in the
ground give it some water fight off
invaders and wait a little while after a
few weeks with a little look you might
end up with a head of lettuce
that's a lot of work for a hundred
calories but what if we had an easier
way of doing things one that didn't
require any soil used much less water
and grew faster where food could
actually grow itself
[Music]
by 2050 the world's population is
expected to reach almost 10 billion
people that's a lot more mouths to feed
but only 11 percent of land is even
suitable for agriculture so farmers will
have to turn to innovative and more
efficient farming practices for a
solution one of the most promising is a
method called
aquaponics which doesn't require any
soil and involves raising fish and
plants together in a contained system
there are several different setups you
can use but here's how the most popular
method works the process begins at the
fish rearing tank here highly adaptable
fish like tilapia are given plenty of
fish food which also leads to plenty of
waste the solid waste is filtered out by
flowing water but the water which is
still full of ammonia from the fish
excrement is mixed with special plastic
pieces naturally occurring bacteria grow
on these surfaces which helps convert
the toxic ammonium and the water into
nitrites and then nitrates
nitrates are basically plant food so the
nutrient-rich water flows out into the
growing area where seedlings on floating
rafts can absorb the food directly
through their roots no soil required
above them energy-efficient LED lights
are adjusted to provide the optimal
color spectrum all of this comes
together helping the plants grow up to
twice as fast as land crops and because
the plant roots purify the water the
cycle can start all over again
commercial systems can yield up to 12
times as much produce per square foot as
traditional farming methods leafy greens
like lettuce are the easiest crops to
grow but they often focus on more
valuable herbs like basil and mint
aquaponics is one of the most
sustainable agricultural systems but it
still has a long way to go before
becoming a go-to farming method new
developments are continuing to make the
process more customizable automated and
efficient than ever who knows in the
future your salad might even be grown by
a fish
[Music]
what food would you grow in your
aquaponic system let us know in the
comments below
[Music]